not one more American life should be
lost because our lawmakers failed to
secure our borders that's why we are
calling on Congress to fix our terrible
immigration laws stop catch and release
to end deadly sanctuary cities to stop
the visa lottery program and a lot more
well President Trump today previewing
what we can expect to hear when he
announces a major immigration overhaul
tomorrow and as we witness last week in
South Texas
this is beyond crisis point now okay we
have updates we're gonna bring you
tomorrow on New Mexico a story in New
Mexico that's been completely lost on
most in the media and we're told two
main points in the president's new
immigration plan will be securing the
border and instituting now this
merit-based immigration system the goal
is to reduce the number of illegals
admitted due to family ties right now 66
percent of 1.1 million green cards are
doled out just because of family
relationships they want to invert that
with merit-based emigration joining us
now is House Minority Whip Steve Scalise
congressman is there a coalition that
would support flipping the narrative
from entire family trees coming in here
to people we supposedly need because
there are no Americans to do these jobs
I'm not for increasing the number of of
legal immigrants I think 1.1 million
it's enough president I think is going
to keep it at the same number but if
you're gonna keep it at the same number
and not reduce it this seems to make
sense
yell or in in there's no talk of
increasing number what there is talk of
is getting back to rule of law securing
the border going to a merit-based system
and think about this right now we've got
some of the dumbest laws on the books if
we educate somebody in America to be a
computer scientist and engineer jobs we
need in America they want to stay in
America we forced them to leave the
country to compete against us while
we've got the Visa Lottery where we
literally plug names out of a hat
in many cases from countries that don't
like us to bring them here why don't we
flip that narrative we have caps on
different countries so if you're coming
from India you might wait 20 years
whereas if you're coming from a Honduras
you may wait six years to come here and
then the feel like you talked about the
family tree issue let's get to a merit
a system where we have rule of law and
where we ultimately get back to those
basic foundational principles where you
come to America the American choice and
video it's not about what you're talking
about we're seeing video of what I saw
last week at the border which is
basically people I love the guy filming
that's just one of the best he's like a
local reporter but people are just
waiting for the Border Patrol and just
they're just pulling them up processing
them in about 24 hours and releasing
them but that's that goes to the asylum
laws which Lindsey Graham wants to
address but I mean the Democrats gonna
agree to any of the stuff or they gonna
own the issue is that the goal here make
them all if they don't move Democrats in
middle America are actually for this the
socialist Democrats here in Washington
are not and it shows the divide not
within the country chosen divided within
their party you've got to end
catch-and-release
you've got in these magnets that are
forcing people to come here the
breakdowns in the asylum law that's
gonna be some of the things that I think
people are gonna be excited about we got
a hundred thousand people just coming in
last month by the way Angela I want to
CNN's favorite Liberal analyst said this
tonight about the president's plan you
cannot develop policy absent people and
compassion it does not work it results
not just in hurt individuals but also
hurt families as at the end of the day
what they're saying is you have to be
amazingly brilliant you probably have to
be wider this is reminiscent to me of
what happened before the civil rights
Muro it really began Chris Cuomo all
right did they have any idea what
they're talking about I mean what are
you tell to a person who's been waiting
in line legally ten years to come to
America when you're gonna allow somebody
that just walks out there one of them
because you have laws that allow them to
do it you know you literally read a
script and you can come here illegally
in place of that person that's been
waiting in line ten years a point system
I don't know how this actually plays out
with a bureaucracy your age English
proficiency again you can game all this
stuff this doesn't mean my offer of
employment above a certain wage
threshold educational and vocational
certifications look I think in the end
this issue if properly messaged will be
another huge winner for the president
although his numbers are not good on
immigration now have you seen this I
don't know if it's big
people are seeing these videos and just
frustrated and they're like why isn't he
fix this and they're impatient but his
numbers for his dedication to this issue
are not I know where they want he when I
go to in and I've been a lot of states a
lot of swing states of course I was in
Louisiana with the president yesterday
there are the lines to see this
president are on will tell me about it
we have so much money you raised last
night how much money and Norrland
dollars and it was sold out there were
people that were literally being turned
away this president has stood up for the
things that he promised he's getting us
back to rule of law he's got a good
immigration plan that actually gets us
back to a merit-based system four
million one night and alive thousand
people illegally crossing a day many
cases and the Democrats want to own that
most of America is not most Democrats
are congressmen it's great to see you as
always